but we begin with a very serious
development in Russia's war on Ukraine
an alarming situation in Poland our NATO
Ally where a missile landed in a village
killing two people now it happened just
across Ukraine's border after Russia's
biggest missile barrage of the War
caused heavy damage across Ukraine and
this morning Poland's president said it
appears to be quote an unfortunate
accident and President Biden says it's
very possible very possibly says that
the missile came from Ukraine Chris
lifts say is there Chris good morning to
you sounds they still have a lot to sort
out there
yeah good morning Gail now both the
president of Poland and the head of NATO
are saying it was likely the cause of a
Ukrainian response to a barrage of
missiles and not a Russian attack
of the thousands of missiles fired since
the start of Russia's War few could
determine its future as much as this one
the blast killed two people on a farm in
peshavadu a small Border Town in Poland
but with global implications
unlike Ukraine Poland is a member of
NATO if this was Russian attack it could
trigger a military response against
Russia from the U.S and the rest of the
alliance Poland has determined the
missile was made by Russia but that does
not mean it was fired by Russia says
President Joe Biden it's unlikely in the
minds of the trajectory that it was
fired from Russia but we'll see
U.S officials say the missile could also
have been launched by Ukrainian forces
in an effort to deflect a crushing Salvo
aimed at Ukraine's electrical grid the
most massive since the start of the war
but Ukraine was quick to point the
finger at Moscow
this is a Russian missile attack on
collective security said Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski this is a
very significant escalation we must act
in the attack Russia fired more than 90
missiles and drones across Ukraine
plunging 10 million households Into
Darkness the government says but Ukraine
says it managed to intercept most of
them with its own air defense missiles
a remarkable achievement in itself now
overshadowed
now it's important to remember that the
blast in Poland was caused by Ukrainian
air defenses they were precisely that
defenses against the latest missile
attack by Russia that have killed more
than 6 000 civilians in Ukraine since
the start of this war and now whether
directly or indirectly to more civilians
in Poland Nate
Chris Lipson in Ukraine thank you